[Music]
we're about to take a nice 15 day cruise
this is a capital for the bridge
a hong kong president tested positive
for corona values we were assured that
it was not a problem this thing was
spreading through the boat
[Music]
the ship would remain under quality for
14 days 14 days a room that's 4x3
check with our medical staff if you have
experienced
fever
cheese
the diamond princess was ground zero the
u.s officials debate whether to bring
the americans back you need to get us
off the ship where we all get sick and
die it's very intense and they said okay
just people who don't have covet how are
you feeling they didn't know who had the
covet that was the medical examination
our team went on board they started to
load all americans for transport to the
airport on the way to the airplane test
results would come back positive
pandemonium ensues the president is just
furious our numbers are going to go up
they didn't know how to handle a single
cruise ship they can't get that right
how are they going to get the rest of
this right honorable that there was a
pandemic to our harbor we realized there
were many more cruise ships out there
why did the cruise ships keep sailing
you